téléphone pliable connectivité 5 g avec
sa nouvelle génération d'appareils
galaxy samsung veut damer le pion à son
rival à pau le fabricant sud coréen
présente 4 nouveaux téléphones
intelligents d'abord l'appareil pliable
galaxy z flip qu'on promet beaucoup plus
robuste que le foll de première
génération
samsung assure que les cranberries
ultra-fin peut être replié plus de 200
mille fois sans problème mais à 1800
dollars canadiens ils étaient au moins
de consommateurs qu'à la collection
galaxy s 20 qui est presque deux fois
moins cher mais entièrement compatible
avec les réseaux 5g l'écran de ce
téléphone à une définition de 8 k est le
modèle le plus cher offre la caméra la
plus puissante sur le marché samsung a
vendu 70 millions de téléphones dans le
monde au cours du dernier trimestre ces
quatre millions de moins que son rival
à pau
[Musique]